i can just clarify i don't necessarily
love love basis i don't think he's like
the most ethical person in the world but
i do think like his process is
fascinating and he's kind of like a
perfect super villain that's why i said
i like you take him over over musk
though like i just like both i don't i
think they're like brilliant innovators
choose one dog choose one holding back
well what do you want you want guys you
want real money or do you want perceived
value that's basically what it is like
if you if you want perceived value
that's musk if you want real money
that's basically but i like must've
social equity i think that's such a cool
way he built that yes yeah i like the
memes are great i think musk is more
rare than bezos
bezos there will be another badass
businessman to come around in 20 years
my dad said this when walmart was
running everything he's like walmart's
gonna get taken down by something when i
moved here sears was the company yep
that's just that's america that's
capitalism i don't know that we're going
to see another musk for a long time and
girls hate musk which makes them sick
that makes it fun dude the amount
you almost like them more because girls
will be like he's the worst he's an
idiot and then you before you know it
you're like actually he's the best
girls say that about musk i feel like so
many women don't like much
they hate him really yeah you just super
rich dude that doesn't kind of play by
the rules posts like you know [ __ ] posts
and i think first of all he i'll tell
you what's better
he built his company he willed his
company into existence yeah that's
what's cool about his white kanye
i've noticed girls hate on billionaires
in the way that dudes will hate on like
super hot girls yeah
personality yeah they're like
idiots
she just models a [ __ ] and then if
she's like oh you wanna [ __ ] be like
yeah of course absolutely yeah yeah yeah
i would marry you today are you talking
about
yeah the yeah the bezos thing that's
interesting to me is like
he didn't invent anything new
he just perfected something that already
exists
and i know that elon didn't invent
anything new but like clearly his
technology for electric cars is far
superior than anybody else's like
bezos is still using the same trucks to
ship you see one of those changing the
world in a more material way i don't
know if it's uh well which one is that
uh musk because you go what bezos is
offering
probably just by virtue of like
progression we would have had a way to
order everything pretty cheaply from one
place yeah i think a curated ordering
system probably would exist but what
musk is doing potentially that
takes it off and then lands
yeah i guess what i'm saying is i'm in
i'm weirdly
more impressed with what bezos did oh i
kind of played misery right yeah yeah
because there's so much more competition
it's like so many people are shipping
packages every single day right like the
guy just found a way to make tape not
annoying to come to break when you open
the package
like how did nobody think about that
before like that enough is more to me
that's more impressive than a electric
car
there's electric [ __ ] in cars all the
time i've been driving electric cars
since i'm i'm a little kid those little
[ __ ] toy cars are all electric
electric cars exist they just found a
way to make it bigger tape that breaks
but also stays together
that's genius nice yeah
no no this is the worst take you've ever
yeah i know but i'll tell you here's
empty here's the three
category no no i guess what i'm trying
to say is he was competing with so bezos
did tape you did yours
no no so basically he looked at this
business that everybody does right and
he found a way to perfect it elon is
doing a business that nobody does
but i don't think why he's so so he's
competing with nobody that's not true
before
everybody says that the first one was
electric
electric car that existed they had a
documentary called who killed the
electric car because they were the ev1
yeah i didn't know what it's called but
they they were around like the early
2000s and then just went away they got
like 45 miles between charges with 90
miles between charges whatever it was
and then just went away right and other
companies have all been racing to this i
talked to a guy at uh an auto shop who
after our tesla got damaged um
uh but they didn't exist right he said
this guy he said tesla's legitimately
beyond even like engine and battery and
all that [ __ ] is changing the way cars
are made like the body it's just
everything is done so efficiently so
there was competition in that sense and
everybody's trying to make electric what
was the other electric car company that
existed while
tesla was taking whoever made that
[ __ ] ev1 that couldn't handle that
chevy made the vault there no no no no
no what was the leaf with the just the
electric car company there wasn't
anything you're slicing it very thin now
we're literally talking about electric
car companies and there's only
the automotive systems car companies are
making electric cars so just because
they're not exclusively making electric
cars so because obviously
not fully electric so because gm yeah
chevy volt fully electric was before
tesla nissan leaf fully electric before
testing before we started buying teslas
for those before you started buying
doesn't exist until you buy one i don't
think there were massive no i don't
think the masses had teslas until what
2011.
are we slicing thin exactly
yeah it's the same [ __ ] they're both
there my point is my point is tesla
comes out and it's one of one
and it's amazing what he did he killed
the dealerships he the assembly line
like this no it's brilliant it's
brilliant what he did i'm not i'm not
questioning what he did what he built is
absolutely amazing and his ability to
play into internet culture and use that
to build social equity and have people
essentially invest in him like he
understood that like he is the company
so as famous as he becomes is as
valuable as the company becomes and we
all believe that he is the smartest
person in the world 100 percent there's
no pump
he know how to pump
he know how to pump and he used the
internet to do it he had to figure that
out and there's how many comics do we
know that can't even figure out how to
put up their [ __ ] clips online yeah
right and it's like and it's right there
it's right there for them to do it they
don't know what to do he's a pump no
dump guy real talk 100 pump and hold
pump and hold and he's built it and
that's genius what i think is that we're
so wow
i mean straight up pump it and then he
had now access to billions of dollars
and then keeps on reinvesting it yeah
100 what i think is we're so wowed by
what he's doing because he's uh
innovating he's creating new technology
the electric car is new for us we're
like oh [ __ ] that's amazing the rocket
to the moon that is
and landing that's new so we i think we
undermine what bezos did i think it's
kind of similar to like gates in a way
where it's just like i don't know what
gates really made but the guy made
billions of dollars and bezos what'd he
do he found a way to like deliver [ __ ]
in a day that's not that interesting but
the organizational processes put
together to deliver all this stuff is
[ __ ] unbelievably fascinating and if
and and you you run a business we run a
business organizing a business is
[ __ ] hard
yeah and that [ __ ] found a way
to do it and make it profitable like the
business makes money yeah elon's barely
makes money but you're talking about it
in two different ways when we talk about
who's legend that's the equivalent of
like you're talking about best action
figure hero and you go arnold
schwarzenegger and you're talking about
their acting process and i'm like dude i
like that he you know hurts the stuntman
like to me i'm saying elon musk like as
a like whatever public figure is the
coolest yes if you're saying what they
actually built better you go yeah maybe
yeah and remember he built paypal before
that so
yeah we weren't arguing who was better
on twitter
what he said earlier is kind of the same
eli uh jeff bezos was the legend
businessman ever and that's super
impressive but i think we're gonna get
another one of him i think elon musk is
more rare i see what you're saying and
that's why i value that i've seen it
continue to come up around but true
innovation doesn't come around that
often yeah okay i hear you on that i
think that makes sense
i just i just hope that we're not
undermining his innovation within
business no he's a loose cannon and
bezos has been consistently great
yes but i don't mind that you're a loose
cannon yeah i'm just saying like
his ability if bezos didn't pick [ __ ]
books and i think this whole space thing
for him is basically his way of going
like i could do that [ __ ] too i just
pick books
like i literally i think it's like this
[ __ ] ain't hard you just put the smart
people in position you organize and then
you have them execute you see how quick
i made a lot more
exactly like i literally think that's
what it is for him you think he's like
you think this guy's smarter than me
it's not that hard yeah
who's the smart one here's more money
you go build it oh we need more money
here's more money go build it so i i
think that's what the ego thing about
it's not really about space it's about
people valuing what space is conquering
yeah
or just oh my god space is so cool at
star trek you must be the smartest
person if you know how to make space
[ __ ] because selling books doesn't make
me think there's a third guy you don't
have a tesla
elon musk doesn't affect your day-to-day
life nearly as much as jeff bezos your
day-to-day life is way better for 98 of
the population because it hasn't been
interesting yeah yeah yeah
again i think that is just like like
ryan said that's the nature of the beast
in capitalism someone is going to come
someone's going to be better than bezos
at some point it might not happen for a
few decades but someone's going to be
better i don't think we're going to see
an elon musk i don't remember an elon
musk in my lifetime i remember the
waltons before bezos and whoever the
[ __ ] sears roebuck whoever that was
before that that's the nature that musk
thing is just more rare
yeah do you val it's like do you value
greatness or like unique
greatness
um i think i see what you're saying
the unique part yeah
hmm they're both great
and and bezos has affected my day-to-day
more i gave back the tesla i like
elon more
i want to like actually i don't know
personality-wise
yeah i killed bezos no personality-wise
like
elon seems fun online though in person
apparently he's weird i know people know
him
he's in real life he's like
check out his meme like he's like beavis
hilarious yeah hilarious apparently he's
not look that's super yeah basil seems
more social
yeah he seems more normal 100
and what he's doing is also seems more
normal yeah right like but
yeah i don't know that's an interesting
one
i think we all like the trope of the
kooky
scientist billionaire
yeah yeah
again that's a [ __ ] dude we've been
waiting to see that our whole lives we
hear about einstein this [ __ ] weirdo
scientist with the crazy hair yeah
that's the closest that i know if you
think he's a fraud fine but let's just
take it at face value who
elon musk
a lot of people think elon's a fraud i'm
not i'm not talking to anyone in this
room i'm talking to people listening a
lot of people are like oh he didn't
invent paypal he hopped on the board or
whatever he didn't invent the electric
car he hopped on the board apparently if
you dig
there's it's not as
great as it seems self-driving cars
aren't really self-driving yet like yeah
but i don't let's take it all at face
value what he did he's the closest thing
he's a nazi yeah he's a nazi
nazi faction
so he has a ukrainian nazi factory
yeah
but yeah i if are they gonna stuff the
jews and those holes in the ground that
he's been building
is that what the boring company is
really about
is
is that how they're going to clean up
the traffic in l.a they're taking the
jews underground i don't know i thought
no that's not a dude okay make your
point akash i just think he's the
closest thing we've had dying since
einstein in our lifetime yeah this kooky
scientist guy is changing the world as
far as we know it yeah that's him bezos
but if he didn't do all those things why
do you think
i believe he's i think he did all these
things but there's a lot of people who
were like nah elon musk is full of [ __ ]
whatever and then i choose not to listen
to them
yeah as a pop culture figure he's cooler
as a business you know if you're like
studying businessmen then yeah whatever
boring basis oh sorry i just got a tweet
that says that tomorrow they're gonna
launch more starlink satellites which
are going to give
wi-fi to all of these cut off uh
ukrainians
pretty good
what's bezos doing sending them a couple
books
you sent them the art of war
[Laughter]
easy to hate on bezos man y'all are
tripping bro
i think basil's got it
sucks dude stinks why why do you hate
bezos oh [ __ ] dork dog do you like it
but eulon's not do you like no you're
not cool as [ __ ] yo you don't be getting
he'd be bagging [ __ ] he got mad baby
mama's out there hosting snl how was
your african man bro we all apparently
showed up to snl with a bunch of
sketches he wanted to do too fire love
all of it [ __ ] [ __ ] matt
cookie no he's more likeable for sure
basil sucks yeah
you know we could really streamline this
process suck my dick dawg
you don't think elon does that all right
no not on twitter that's the beta's
whole ethos you know
this is how russia
wins they just put [ __ ] on twitter and
then akash is like yeah this is what's
up
these are the people no i don't think
that i do think you give back the car
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you gave back the car you [ __ ] fraud
why
it didn't have enough uh we didn't get
the good engine dove got us a cheap
battery
the last milestone worked well for me
yeah didn't know you're going to drop
the philly everyday across the country
where do you need to go philly yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
without charging it in the middle of the
night huh is it pain in the ass to
charge
yeah just my wife is driving mad lately
pulling over yeah yeah you see this yeah
yeah yeah
yeah keep going keep going
you just bought up the social media
presence bro you don't even like what he
makes
you don't even like what you make you
don't even like it enough to buy a new
one why don't you buy the one with the
bigger engine i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna
win he's gonna win i'm waiting on this
[ __ ] eight thousand dollar build back
better credit to pass
being completely transparent
this is [ __ ] see you need the
government to help you out mess up
welfare [ __ ]
hmm
indians are way cheaper than jews
you can't dangle a 8 000 credit in my
face and then take that [ __ ] away and
expect me to make the purchase
you